education is the way out for immigrants
my mom recognized that I was a merchant
an entrepreneur a promoter at school
failure you failed school school failed
me schools failing entrepreneurs every
single day that was because it's not
built to poor entrepreneurship it's
built for workers you know if you're
being taught to play within the lines
and there's nothing being taught that
maps to the entrepreneurial market as a
matter of fact my biggest cynicism when
I sit across an entrepreneur today is if
they are too successful at school I
probably look at Ivy League grad
starting startups right now
with more of a negative light than I do
somebody who wasn't because what I've
learned over the last five to seven
years and by the way in the last two or
three years I've taken a step back on
this because there's too many
entrepreneurial friends who've gone to
great schools that have been successful
so this is not a blanket statement but I
will tell you that in a world of private
schools in a world of mommy and daddy
having a lot of connections that when
you go from 12 15 18 years of that
ecosystem and you go into a market and
you create an app the market doesn't
give a crap who your dad is the market
responds to your product and a lot of
these kids have not been able to take
the punch in the mouth that comes along
with entrepreneurship